[Aplausos]
ah
la escritura ha sido parte de la
sociedad porque cada vez que han
existido eventos importantes o hechos
históricos han quedado escritos o
cimentados en 'la por eso cada vez que
la sociedad busca progresar retoma esos
escritos para no volver a cometer esos
mismos errores
y así comenzó nuestra escritura con
simples dibujos o jeroglíficos hasta
tener la escritura tan desarrollada que
conocemos al día de hoy pero ahora bien
les quiero hacer una pregunta ustedes
saben o se han preguntado cuántos
cuantos libros se han escrito por la
humanidad hasta la actualidad
si un dato interesante porque se han
escrito cerca de 130 millones de libros
hasta la actualidad pero porque digo que
es un dato interesante porque en la
actualidad aprendemos a leer y escribir
más pronto pero entendemos lo que
hacemos más tarde y si yo era una de
ellas que odiaba leer y peor aún
escribir donde mis clases de literatura
y gramática eran las más largas y
aburridas pero nunca me llegué a
imaginar que la escritura podría llegar
a hacer la diferencia entre la vida y la
muerte y me di cuenta de esto porque
hacía lo que amaba que era practicar
deporte y ayudar a la gente y hace ya
tres años tuve una experiencia donde
conocí a una realidad diferente del
ecuador donde tener una donde tenía
demasiadas necesidades y pobreza donde
tener una tienda cerca era algo
impensable o que llegar a comer pan
fuera un lujo porque estamos
acostumbrados
todo en la palma de nuestra mano
cuando regrese de esta experiencia
me detectaron una enfermedad llamada
meningitis la meninge es una capa que
recubre al cerebro
y cuando ésta se llega a inflamar
demasiado se puede llegar a romper daño
dando daño cerebral pero este no fue mi
caso gracias a dios y un temprano
diagnóstico pero que sí dejó varias
secuelas donde yo ya no podía hacer lo
que tanto amaba que era practicar
deporte o ayudar a la gente y mucha
gente me decía necesitas ayuda
profesional para poder salir de esto
pero por suerte logré encontrar la
escritura
y como él no era el solo hecho de
comenzar a escribir todo lo que se me
venía a la mente sino las cosas buenas
que me pasaban durante el día pero esa
era la parte difícil del ejercicio
encontrarle algo bueno a los días malos
pero recordé y empecé por cosas simples
de la vida
como veis la naturaleza hoy levantarme
más temprano para poder ver un simple
amanecer para muchos pero el regalo más
maravilloso que nos regala naturales a
todos los días o tal vez en un día
caluroso recibir esa brisa refrescante
en el rostro
y esas cosas yo las anotaba pero porque
las cosas buenas porque el cerebro
olvida cerca del 50% del aprendizaje las
24 horas y tan solo recuerda el 10% a
las 48 horas por esto esa es la forma en
cómo uno puede sobrellevar los malos
momentos y las malas cosas que le pasan
en la vida pero además de eso la
escritura tiene múltiples beneficios
cómo disminuir el estrés hacernos más
felices aprender más rápido ayudarnos a
tomar mejores decisiones y algo muy
interesante que es que si nosotros
escribimos todos los días tendríamos un
registro histórico de nuestros
pensamientos y el poder ver ese
crecimiento como personas o el solo
hecho de ver esa evolución de nosotros
mismos es algo fascinante
por eso la escritura me llevo donde
estoy y el poder haber salido adelante
ahora pude escoger mi carrera que tanto
me gusta y que amo y pude emprender
que sí me dio miedo emprender y sacar mi
propia empresa claro que me dio miedo
pero me preguntaba qué pasaría si es que
el día de mañana me volviera a suceder
lo mismo pero esta ocasión ya no
correría con tanta suerte hice todo lo
que quise hacer
así que si me lancé emprendí y me fue
bien
ahora estoy donde estoy y por eso es la
invitación que les hago a ustedes el
escribir las cosas buenas que les pase
en la vida porque para mí fue la
diferencia entre la vida y la muerte
muchas gracias
[Aplausos]